today's topic trisha paytas again yes
sir man you heard her last video right
the brain is not fully developed to 25
for women and up to 30 for men
they shouldn't be able the age of
consent should be what 25 if she said
damn right and if you get involved with
these and you're much substantially
older what does that mean that you're
doing something predatory
yes
turns out she's got an only fence and
she provided one of her backup dancer to
do a video with her she invited him to
come do uh a scene with her right
clapping cheeks no yeah because she does
that she sells you know and i'm not mad
at it i'm i'm pro that go do that if you
want to do that yeah so as a 31 year old
she invited this 22 year old to come do
a scene with her but it's okay nine
years
but the brain's not fully developed
fair
can't consent
nope tell 30. i just think it's
interesting how this man who's got a
20-year difference can't do it she got a
nine-year difference with someone whose
brain is not fully developed eight years
from fully developing because you know
for men yeah but she did an adult scene
with him and published it online so
let's hypothetically take the logic
let's take the logic she brought this
person she profited off that imagine
this man was
15 and she was 26 because by her logic
that's how this works not age of consent
not really mentally developed yet okay
can't he's not a real adult
she basically brought on an underage
person to come do an adult video with
her for the world to see
i just think it's so crazy
that these people get online and act
sanctimonious like they should don't
stink like they ain't never dated
somebody was substantially younger or
been involved with them in a romantic
capacity she's famous right she she's
got a huge following he was her backup
dancer
right so she done paid his bills power
dynamic
but since going to get out and talk
about people who are just dating regular
folks that's just funny you know what's
funny to me club go ahead what paytasks
means is friends
that's what's funny to me the whole this
whole time what pintas means in french
brah
you can't make this [ __ ] up that's
what's funny to me
i can't tell them if you know you know
if you don't
look it up but someone's going to put it
in someone's going to put it in there
i'll leave it i'll bleep it they're
going to put it in the comments i'll
leave it say it
stop
you said it in krill say it in english
you know the word the real word no no
the one that starts with
her name means
literally you can't make this [ __ ] up
and i'm not even mad at her for doing
that it to me it's the hypocrisy of
these people the hypocrisy right they
get up here and they say you should
never do it listen our only stance was
they're grown people let them lift their
lives but that's what we were just
that is your standard your standard by
your own standard you should be canceled
you should be seen as a huge boo-boo
forget a red flag
communist china you the whole flag
you're the whole country and you want to
get out here and talk about other people
what they should or shouldn't be doing
are you mad
so again this is why i tell you guys be
careful who you take your cues from
because a lot of these people will sit
up here and say you're evil you're the
devil you deserve to be canceled are the
very same people who do the same
stuff behind closed door and much worse
and much worse you got and much worse
you got juice
i don't know what's going on her head i
don't know what kind of problem she got
i don't know what it is but it's just
crazy that you didn't adulting with
someone you consider to be underage yet
you want to act sanctimoy's about
someone having a relationship with
someone that age crazy i'll be back
because [ __ ] and different than
you that's it
girl that's it be an adult all right at
the end of the day people should make
their own decisions if you want to bang
one of your friends your backup dancers
for do that i don't care it's none of my
business everyone's a grown ass adult
don't go about lecturing people when you
take profit oh
that whole other [ __ ] you're
talking about is just dating he's 39
she's 20 whatever i don't care i said it
before but you're making profit on his
ass not when you're paying his bills but
if you're not talking about power
dynamics here boo-boo i don't know what
the hell it is oof that's a no that's
pretty much it for us i just want you
guys to know this just just so you know
just be very careful all right a lot of
people want things they want to sell you
guys on these ideas because it sounds
great on twitter they read it on twitter
they internalize this ideology without
realizing how it's not actually
applicable to reality the reality is
that dating is complicated people like
age differences people like money
differences they people like power
differences height differences all kinds
of things and just because there's some
imbalance doesn't mean that something
inappropriate has happened okay
so just be mindful of that try to see
things on an extra layer and i think
that's it i don't have to say anymore
keep it short
[Music]
i